[Music]
why are people resistant to the idea
that dna has a powerful influence on our
personality and our behavior
i think in part people are resistant to
the notion
of the importance of genetics because
they don't understand it
and that's one of the reasons i wrote my
book blueprint how dna makes us who we
are but you know actually i find there's
much more resistance in the media
than there is in the public i've given
probably 30
talks to fairly large public groups and
it's amazing to me
that i hardly ever run into hostility
mostly what i run into is people saying
i didn't know about that that sounds
really cool and the data sound
impressive
and people don't have a hard time
accepting
that inherited dna differences are an
important
answer to the question of what makes us
who we are it doesn't explain
everything by any means but the point of
my book is
that inherited dna differences is the
major systematic force
making us who we are as individuals our
personality
our mental health and illness and our
cognitive abilities and disabilities
these same genetic data provide the best
evidence we have for the importance of
the environment
but the environment works very
differently from the way we thought it
worked
and we can go into that in a bit can we
talk in more detail about
how genetics affects your behavior in
the ways that you were saying
yes there's so many background
issues to talking about genetic
influences
on behavioral traits and one place that
i think is important to start is with
the idea of genes as destiny
i gave a philosophical evening
conversation last night on the topic of
do genes control our destiny because you
say genes
and people think of hard-wired
puppeteers
making us do things you know
deterministic
and part of that's because we learn
about genetics from
mendel mendel you remember did
experiments with pea plants and he was
essentially studying
single gene mutations in pea plants if
you were a pea plant you'd like your
seeds to be nice and round and smooth
there's a mutation a single gene
mutation that causes them to be wrinkled
so that these single gene mutations
are deterministic and hardwired and
necessary and sufficient
for humans there are maybe seven eight
thousand
single gene disorders most of them
thankfully are very rare
but if you had one of these like on the
tip of chromosome 4
you know we have 23 pairs of chromosomes
the tip of chromosome 4
has a gene that if if if you receive the
inherit of the mutated version of it
you have huntington's disease which is a
neurological degeneration that happens
later in life
and if you have that mutation you will
die from huntington's
it doesn't matter what your environment
is your exercise regime your food
it will kill you it's necessary and
sufficient
and so those are very important for the
people who get them but what we've
learned
in the last decade is that that's not
where
most of the genetic influence comes from
for complex traits
like those who study in psychology and
common disorders
like in medicine heart disease obesity
diabetes for example
there's strong genetic influence but
there's no evidence
for major gene effects that is any one
bit of dna is making a huge difference
what it's about this heritability is
about
thousands of tiny dna differences
that together have an impact on a
disorder
so that's a whole new ballgame you know
single gene genetics would be rather
simple you just
find the gene you find out what it does
wrong and you try to change it although
we're not very good at doing those
things
but here we've got thousands of little
dna differences
that are making you predispose say to
schizophrenia
or in my case to obesity and
it's a it makes it go from a
deterministic
hard-wired single gene concept
to a probabilistic propensity
and that's what's hard for people to
understand so if i
say you have a 15 well in my case you
know my
um we put these thousands of dna
differences together and we call them
polygenic scores
my highest risk polygenic score
is for body mass index weight so
my genetic score just looking at my dna
alone it says
i'm about at the 94th percentile for
weight
my actual weight is at the 70th
percentiles
so i'm still you know borderline obese
but um you know this raises a lot of
issues about destiny it doesn't mean
i'm i throw up my hands and say oh well
i'm a genetic family nothing i can do
about it
which is what people worry about instead
i find it very motivating because i know
it's not destiny
if i don't eat i won't gain weight and
then people like
you know you know many people in the
audience will
just say well get a grip a little
self-control here don't eat so much
but people who like me have this
propensity to put on weight
and we don't really respond to food cues
in the same way
and and there's this sense of satiety
that psychologists talk about
that is if you're full you probably stop
eating and i sort of say at dinner i'm
out with friends
i'm full i don't want any more but if
there's food left on the table
as we're talking before you know it i've
eaten most of that food
even though i wasn't hungry particularly
it's just i don't have the same sense of
oh i'm full i absolutely don't want
anything more
and the other thing is sensitivity to
food cues you know when we're bombarded
by food cues
easy enough to say well you know just
get a grip resist those
things but i can't walk past the base
pastry shop for example the smells
my mouth is watering just thinking about
it you know
so um we need to respect these
differences and obesity is a great
example because there's this stuff going
on about food
fat shaming you know people even
suggesting
that on the nhs if you go in for an
obesity related disorder like diabetes
or cardiovascular disease
why should the society pay for it you
know because it's your problem
well one answer to that is we pay for
lung cancer treatment for people who
smoked
cigarettes all their life and that's a
lot i would say
because i don't smoke properly that
would be an easier thing to resist
but you know people need to know that
and i bet this will surprise people that
individual differences
is in body mass index which is weight
corrected for height
is about between 60 and 70 percent that
means of the differences between people
that you know are so apparent
in their weight almost two-thirds of
those differences
can be ascribed to inherited dna
differences
that came from that first cell with
which you were born
and that's the cool thing about dna is
it doesn't change
during your lifespan those inherited dna
differences that were formed uniquely by
the egg and the sperm that created your
first zygote
those that same dna is in every one of
the trillions of cells in your body
there are some mutations you pick up
along the way but the
systematic influences of heredity are
there in that first zygote
so that makes dna an incredible
predictor because there's nothing else
we have
that allows you to predict from early in
life and this is why medicine is so keen
on this this is why the nhs is talking
about
making dna testing available for
everyone
because medicine there's two big
movements in medicine one is preventive
medicine
and that's the idea of instead of
waiting for people to have a heart
attack and then trying to fix it
and it's said that a severe heart attack
costs 700 000 pounds
all in you know there's a lot of
treatment afterwards and all that
let alone the personal suffering and the
reduction in quality of life
so waiting until something happens and
then trying to cure it
is expensive and it's painful if you
could
prevent that heart attack from occurring
it just is a no-brainer because you know
you save all that money you save all
that pain
and so to prevent you need to predict
and dna is the best predictor we have
from early in life
i mean sure you could say because i'm
overweight because i'm a male
because i'm over 60 i'm at on average
you know greater risk for having a heart
attack
but that doesn't give you much power in
predicting that i'm going to have a
heart attack
what's cool about dna is it makes a
specific genetic prediction
for me you know knowing nothing else
about these other characteristics
and and what's great about it with
cardiovascular disease is there's lots
of things you can do
to prevent heart attacks i mean for one
the lowest tech solution
is to pay attention to the messages we
all receive
you know each well exercise you know
those sorts of things but we all kind of
ignore that
if you knew you were at very high risk
though for heart attack
you would pay more attention to it then
you can go higher up in the tech ladder
and
think about more frequent sorts of um
assays you know to to make sure your
arteries aren't clogging too much
and there are now these whole body scans
so you can do more and more
expensive things that you can't do for
everybody but if you can identify people
at very high risk
it seems to be the way to go to prevent
and then the other thing
so the first movement in medicine is
preventative medicine
and and psychology is trying to do this
too moving away from waiting until
you have a problem like obesity or
alcoholism
they're very hard to fix once you've
really had them
better to prevent them and alcoholism is
a great example because you cannot
become alcoholic
unless you drink a whole lot of alcohol
over a long period of time
so um that that's really great for
prevention but the other
major trend in medicine is
what some people call personalized
medicine or in the us they call it
precision medicine so instead of giving
drugs
on a one-size-fits-all basis surely it
has to be better
to say that people with this genetic
profile would profit more from that drug
or that dose and and this is probably
going to drive it even more
there is always people with any drug
that it's really has negative effects on
them
and so if you could identify people who
will have a negative effect
on a negative side effect of this drug
and you know it's not going to work for
them you don't administer it to them
so prevention and personalized medicine
are the reason why medicine is so
excited about this
and estonia and finland already make dna
testing available to anyone who wants it
if you go in the hospital and they take
blood they say would you like to
have us do this dna testing and we'll
tell you you've got risks for things
that we can do something about
and 85 percent of the people say yes
please i'd like to do that
and the nhs matt hadcock wants to do
this
and um it hasn't happened yet
and with all corona and brexit and
everything else i don't know when it's
actually going to happen
but there has been 150 million set aside
to do this on a trial basis you know to
get it going with a few million people
so i find it tremendously exciting and
i've been emphasizing the positive
aspects of this
and partly that's because so many people
are saying
uh the sky's gonna fall if we do these
things you know it's
terrible there's identity issues there's
labeling issues
you know if you knew you were had a risk
for alcoholism
would that mean i mean people think it
means you're going to say oh well i'm
going to be alcoholic
but you know i never see that you know i
see when you identify a risk for someone
they might not do anything about it but
they're more likely to say
yeah i'm going to pay a little bit more
attention to this you know
and i think that's the way it's going to
work at that low
level of information that's why 25
million people in the world
have paid about a hundred pounds to get
this dna testing
because they want to know about their
risk for things they also want to know
about their ancestry and all of that
so i think it's really transformational
and
i'm tremendously excited about it but
what i started to say was
there's plenty of people who worry about
it the doom mongers i call them
and you know that's really unfair
there's a lot of things we need to worry
about what about
you know ai getting a hold of our
genetic information
what about uh insurance companies
knowing that you
have a high cardiovascular risk they're
going to say
they're going to do their best not to
insure you or if they insure you
they're going to say this is going to
cost you a lot of money
insurance companies worry about well if
you knew you were at heart attack risk
and you didn't tell them that's this is
all illegal they're not supposed to use
genetic information you're not either
because if you knew it was genetic you
have it's like a pre-existing condition
it would be illegal not to tell them
but you know this is going to happen
both of these things will happen and
then the insurance companies would have
to pay out
you know for people who took a lot of
insurance to cover
their risk but i think the larger story
here
is i don't see how the insurance
industry
is going to survive the dna revolution
and i think this is the salvation of the
nhs
because the only way to get by in a with
the dna from
information is to spread that risk
you know and to say to have institutions
like nice the national institute for
clinical excellence
who says we start with debate you can't
do everything for everybody
so you've got to ration resources and
you say
in in our research this suggests
it's worthwhile you know this particular
drug even if it's expensive
it really does improve quality of life
but these other drugs that
say in terminal diseases give you 10 an
extra month or so
and it's hugely expensive they say we
can't really afford to do that for
everybody
so i think spreading the risk
is huge you know that that really does
make it important but the second thing
that people don't realize
is that with an insurance-based system
like in the us hospitals get paid
when they treat you for your disorder
they get paid
when i have a heart attack and they have
to fix my heart attack
they don't get paid if i don't have a
heart attack
so there's nothing in it for them to try
to
prevent disorders whereas from a
national health system
that it's a no-brainer that's what you
want to do you want to prevent the
disorders from happening
so i really do think you know as
well covet has really made people
appreciate the nhs
but you know it has been underfunded for
a long time
and it's one of the jewels you know in
the uk that's one of the things
in the world people hold up as you know
there's an nh system that
really works for people at the point of
entry you know and
being an american i'm also a uk citizen
but in america
when people go for jobs you know not not
just the
the lowest jobs but up to the higher
level management jobs
they're much more concerned about the
health care benefits
than they are about the salary because
the
with obama 10 of the people were
uninsured
it's now going up to 20 percent and if
trump is reelected it's going to be
you know 50 50 i mean you know they
they you know i don't they hate
obamacare because it's obamacare i think
but you know it's such an amazing thing
to do but people without health
insurance they die
you know they have to be treated if
they're in an accident they have to be
treated to the point where they're
stable
but then they don't get more treatment
so
i just think this when people think of
the nhs as to the
throwback to the idealism of the
post-world war
second world war and you know that's
when all the big changes happen
and that's when bevan decided that we
should have universal health care
i think now people think oh that's kind
of
past its time it's an old-fashioned idea
we need to have this be
market driven and capitalistic and man i
don't want people making
decisions about my health and my
operations
on a financial basis and that's really
what happens in the states
so i think this should be wonderful for
the national health system
i hope it is a picture of me how would
it work how does it
start to intervene in your life yeah
well ideally and this is what matt
hancock is
moving towards everyone at birth has dna
testing
because you only have to do it once and
once you've got those three billion base
pairs
suppose some other genetic risk is
discovered when they're 15.
you know maybe there's some drug that
people have been taking that we always
thought was okay
and suddenly you know it's not and
you've got to do something
about that especially with people who
are genetically sensible
sensitive so it opens up the possibility
for the rest of your life of getting
information
that would be useful for you or
preventing illness
so um people say oh my god that's
gattaca i know you're too
young i think to know the movie gattaca
i've seen it then i know
um well that's older audiences that's
what they say oh
gosh that's like gattaca but people
don't realize we've been testing
dna testing babies at birth for 50 years
and the reason that started was one of
the first genes that was discovered a
single gene disorder
is called um phenylketonuria
it causes severe mental retardation and
in less than one percent of the
population
but pku is a single gene recessive
disorder you need two doses of it
and when that was discovered they
realized
it was a simple metabolic error error
that's why it's called phenylketonuria
phenylalanine you have trouble breaking
down phenylalanine
and what happens if you can't break it
down is it builds up and if it builds up
in the developing brain in the first few
years of life
it causes severe retardation so much so
that most
pku kids that aren't treated would need
to be institutionalized they can't take
care of themselves
they don't talk you know so it's very
bad news
and um by knowing though that
it's this metabolic error you could
probably even figure out
well it's probably you can't break down
phenylalanine
what if we eliminate phenylalanine from
the diet
and it's mostly in red meats and milk
products
and especially colostrum breast milk the
early breast milk is really high in
femality
by doing that simple in nutritional
intervention you sidestep the problem
[Music]
so i mean that was so brilliant and that
was in the 50s and 60s
the problem is you know so that's a
perfect example you find the gene you
find out what's wrong
and it isn't um a biological
intervention it's
it's simply an environmental
intervention so
that's brilliant the problem is there
are a lot of other examples like that
and partly that's because single gene
disorders are so rare
and most our big problem the real
medical burden
and psychological burden in society is
with these complex
traits and common disorders you know
things like schizophrenia and reading
disability and alcoholism and obesity
and diabetes so these are not things
that are caused by a single gene
and if they're caused by thousands of
little gene effects
it's unlikely you're going to get a
silver bullet there that's just going to
fix the problem
you understand your inherited biology
your dna
in order to get a sense of what you're
more likely to be
up against but then it is up to your
environmental
situation and the decisions you make in
your life to try and mitigate that
it's not it's not just a case of biology
is destiny
no absolutely not biology is destiny it
and it's um informative um
like here's one tough example if you do
23andme
as as say 10 million people have it's
the biggest of these
we call them direct to consumer dna
companies dtc
and so it has about a third of the
market i would say
and one of the things you would find out
if you did that is whether or not you're
at risk for alzheimer's
people know alzheimer's dementia late in
life now
at age 80 10 of people have
at least the beginning stages of
alzheimer's which can last for 15 years
so a lot of us will have it at the age
of 10 at the age of 80
maybe 10 percent of the population but
if you
your results from 23andme could tell you
if you're in the unlucky one percent of
the population
that your risk won't be 10 it will be 60
60 now that's not 100
but as medical risks go 60
is off the scale i mean that's a really
high risk
so for that reason about half of the
people including james watson who
won the nobel prize for double helix
didn't want to know
and if you ask an audience half of them
will say i don't want to know it's going
to ruin my life there's nothing i can do
about it now
but the other half which includes me is
i always want to know information you
know knowledge is power
and forewarned is forearm so even though
we can't
intervene to cure it now that's the goal
you're not going to wait you're not
going to make people better who have
alzheimer's
what you hope to do is to prevent people
from
getting alzheimer's so by being able to
predict genetically you're much more
likely to be able to find interventions
that work
so i'm optimistic that something will be
found before i'm
reaching that age it turns out i did the
testing and i don't have that risk
so but i mean if i had that risk though
and you know i had to say
if you do it with 23 and me you have to
say yes i understand
how you know what a big deal this is
finding out about it
and then again you have to say yes i've
read about it i really understand it yes
i want my results and then you have to
say again
yes i want my results for this because
they want to make sure people don't get
those results unless they've thought
about what this means because
you know it could be devastating for
people and the worst bit about it is
in the end if you are in that one
percent you get a link that says
you might want to find out more about
this whereas you would hope if this were
on the nhs
they would say we've scheduled an
appointment for you to come in to talk
to somebody
and maybe bring a close relative or
something like that you know
um but people do divide down the middle
on this
and i would say i i want to know because
i think there is something you can do
about it
that is if i know it's at a 60 risk for
having alzheimer's
i would first of all try to make sure
economically i'm going to be okay
you know with care homes for elderly
being [ __ ]
you know we need to maybe think more
about
protecting ourselves but then also
socially i mean you want to
set up things with your family to make
sure they understand and
you know so i think there are things you
could do but for me the biggest thing i
think would be
carpe diem you know i'd say i need an
extra dollop but
you know instead of thinking about oh
when i retire i'm going to do this and
i'm going to do that
i'd think a lot more about doing that
stuff now
so um it's a good example of
it kind of ties together a number of the
things that we've been talking about
you mentioned at the start when you talk
to people they're very receptive
but you feel like there's some sort of
buffer or
difficulty with the media and i was
wondering if you could just sort of
expand on that and
why it's hard for your message to
necessarily
be communicated in the way you want it
to be
yeah well that's going to be my how the
light gets in
debate tomorrow is with um yasmine alibi
brown
who's very much on the left and lord
matt ridley
um who well i won't
make too much of a plug for it but we're
talking sort of about
science and politics and genetics and
should they
get mixed up but as alibi
uh yasmin alibi brown will say the left
has been associated
with environment and the right has been
associated with genetics
i think that's incredibly simplistic and
not true
necessarily among friends i know and
so i would say you know even if that
were true
why is the environment good and genetics
bad
more harm by far has been done in
psychology
from environmentalistic perspectives you
know you
when i was in graduate school in the 70s
in the textbooks it would say
schizophrenia is caused by what your
mother did to you in the first three
years of life
man that is as weak as it could be
because you don't find out that they're
schizophrenic until they're 20
in the late teens or early 20s and then
you're told it's because of what you did
early in life which you can't change you
can't go back in time and change that
i mean environment does incredibly
wicked things and in
parenting which interests me a lot it's
mostly mother blaming that's the way the
environment works
you know kids don't do well at school
they have mental health problems
it's basically the mother and mother
blaming is crazy because there's no
evidence to support that
so i don't think the environment should
be good
necessarily and i don't think genetics
should be bad
genetics can do a lot of good for us in
terms of predicting
problems and trying to prevent them
before they occur
with personalized medicine instead of
giving
kids with adhd hyperactivity
methylphenidate you know an amphetamine
which is what they do
in the states 10 of the kids are getting
this
and and it's increasing in the uk well
if you knew that some kids would really
profit from that and it won't hurt them
you could predict predict that
genetically you know okay maybe
but undoubtedly some kids will actually
be harmed by that
and so personalized medicine and
prevention
i think are so positive that for me they
outweigh the negatives but i think we
have to have this discussion
but what i don't like is this knee-jerk
idea that if you're left
you have to deny genetic influence
which is really what it has been up to
now you know just any sort of genetics
was bad
and that's the way it was when i was in
graduate school in the 70s
if genetics schizophrenia is caused by
what your mother does to you in the
first few years of life genetics is not
mentioned
whereas now we know genetics accounts
for most
of the differences between people and
who become schizophrenic or not
and really how severe their
schizophrenia is i don't think there are
many people now
even on the far left who would say oh no
schizophrenia is caused by what your
mother did to you
i mean i i bet if we did a poem most
people would say yeah schizophrenia has
a strong genetic component
and if you're a parent you ought to be
damn glad about that because
you know here you do the best for your
kid you're as good a parent as you can
be
everything's fine until late adolescence
when they start
losing touch with reality they're
isolated they don't have friends and
and then eventually lose touch with
reality
you know that's devastating and if you
really believe that you have molded your
kid to be the way they
are you don't consider genetics i don't
see
i don't see how you can sleep fantastic
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv